unglaublich viele haben sich dieses
spiel wieder gewünscht
die leute sind auf die straßen gegangen
weil sie es wieder sehen wollten
und hier ist es nur wieder meine damen
und herren agrar e
mario ist ein spiel bei dem wir als
kreis andere kreise essen müssen
ja und da dachte ich wieder hochladen
will ich 4013 ja 400 millionen 1000 also
drückt den like button nach oben wenn
ihr boxdorf addario ich bin luca ich
spiele ag rio gehen die ganzen anderen
ich weiß dass ich besser bin nobody can
touch minute angehört was wollt ihr alle
ich kann mich auch hier hinter einfach
verstecken dann kann mich keiner kriegen
das heißt ich kann es sogar allee kann
ich nicht doch gerade ich könnte die
cool abschließen oh mein gott seger was
richtig ist
mario ist ein typisches spiel was ich
früher auf meinem kanal gebracht habe so
vor einem jahr also sehr sehr früher das
war so die zeit wo ich agrio gebracht
habt clever bord akinator und das immer
so jeden tag wir nicht dumm ich war
folglich algerien anteil ich mich auch
jetzt verfolgt er mich super cool dank
an luca du bist super motto karriere
gegessen
he
[Musik]
denn wo soll ich im oder unten gibt es
frei von hamm haben haben haben haben
beiden ziehen sich wieder zusammen dann
esse ich jetzt mein gott dieser seite
denn alle so groß ich will einfach nur
ihnen da unten essen ich weiß nicht wie
der name ausgesprochen
doch durch du dich dich würde ich doch
tatsächlich auch nehmen nein nein der
roten einteiler dich nicht auf nämlich
nicht okay danke ich liebe addario das
ist einfach immer immer immer wenn ich
sage und bogen dann sterbe ich
immer wenn das ist aber ich lasse mich
davon natürlich nicht beeindrucken ich
meine ich sammeln hier weiter meinen
ganzen tank ist wieder von vorne an und
ist natürlich scheiße
hey komm gib mir etwas abbekommen dicker
ich bin ganz neu frisch dabei kam das
wie man reagiert lara potter möchtegern
harry potter ich krieg dich sofort jetzt
hier ab
es ist ein kampf um leben und tod
wer bist du denn je ist das hier im
lande ist das tue ich mich gerade
hollande hat ein bisschen was verloren
hier
was
es habe ich voll bock auf bacon mit
spiegel all das war glaube ich der grund
warum ich agrarium nicht mehr so häufig
gebracht habe weil man hier einfach
seine nerven verlieren guck ich wieder
jedes jahr 2000 der leitung und addario
ruckelt die leute von algari müssen
langsamer wissen dass die krasse server
benötigen bei den ganzen spielern
was ich sagen wollte ich glaube dass das
der grund warum ich ja gar nicht mehr so
etwas hochgeladen habe weil eines meiner
letzten videos war auch wieder was ruhig
bei omega ausgelastet bin es bringt
einen an den rand der verzweiflung das
also addario ist echt sein übels rage
game
gebt mir doch mal irgendwas zu essen
hier bitte jetzt geht es gerade wieder
mit dem ruckeln aber vorhin was ich
zuletzt ich meine maus in eine richtung
geheiratet habe und dann ist in fünf
sekunden später erst wieder wenn ich
eine andere richtung hatte ist ja erst
wieder da hingefahren ist alles leicht
ausbaufähig beispiel obwohl ich schon
sehr viele jahre auf den markt dessen
blog den gefressen
das geht nämlich auch also falls ja gar
nicht kennt es geht auch dass ich mich
mit der leertaste quasi auf teile das
heißt anstößig und ding raus und kann
die leute fressen die in dem in der
ziellinie sind nachteil ist dass ich
jetzt gerade getrennt bin und es dauert
jetzt locker noch eine minute bis sich
wieder zusammen bin
das heißt andere leute die mich jetzt
irgendwie sehen könnten mich einfach
fressen von mark zuckerberg
luca ich bin doch so dummen gott es war
wieder so klar dass ich das nicht
hinkriege okay okay wer du frisst mich
auf ich schwöre ich töte deine familie
in diesem spiel okay lass mich bitte
vielleicht einfach in ruhe das wäre sehr
schön sehr schön ok danke danke schön
danke leute können wir uns vielleicht
wieder zusammenziehen ich habe hier
gerade tatsächlich so ein bisschen angst
dass irgendwie der da oben jetzt
jemanden aussendet um uns alle irgendwie
zu fressen ich bin raus aus der
gefahrenzone das heißt ich ziemlich mal
eben wieder zusammen das hat er zum
glück auch relativ schnell geklappt
dies kam den vbz am rating too much ich
will nur euch alle essen damit ich der
beste bin in dem spiel und ich weiß
nicht wen ich noch essen kann übrigens
diese grünen teile hier sind relativ
schlecht also wenn ich dagegen fahren
dann sterbe ich quasi so harry da oben
könnte ich perfekt essen aber der ist
schneller als ich also kleinere spieler
sind quasi muss ich euch das alles noch
erklären
also ich weiß nicht wie viele von euch
neue zuschauer sind die agave überhaupt
nicht kennen auch hague
ages want you tube ist was soll da ist
ihr euch denn alle immer höher
es hat einfach geklappt ich hätte nie
gedacht dass das klappt was die fitness
games jetzt müssen wir halt nur schauen
dass wir uns irgendwie wieder
zusammenziehen vielleicht und dann auf
die anderen leute drauf gehen und ich
will heute echt noch in die top ten und
ich glaube ich bin davon gerade gar
nicht so krass weit entfernt nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein
[Musik]
dass das sind das sind so das sind so
[ __ ] in diesem in diesem spiel nimmt
das hier ist frei für alle das heißt
jeder spielt auf seine eigenen kosten
keiner machten team allerdings haben
diese zwei die mich gerade getötet haben
sich gegenseitig masse zugesteckt quasi
über dieses dieses zu schießen dinge
kann man sich mit wenigen diese masse zu
stecken und dadurch wurde die türkei
größer als ich und könnte mich konnte
mich töten das ist das ist einfach nicht
cool also wenn ihr wenn ihr mich einfach
so töten könnten einfach mit ja okay ich
wäre froh sondern natürlich andere und
so okay aber es ist blöd dass es illegal
ich zeige euch an du bist du bist ein
fucking biene mein gott was sind denn
das sie für namen wieder kann sich nicht
mehr einer hier nennen lucca so cool ich
schenk dir allem eine masse das wäre
tatsächlich ein name den ich find ja gut
er einfach in den reihen wie so herzlich
in mich reingefahren hague
verpisst euch ich verstehe es nicht gott
meine fresse ich bin ich bin die ganze
zeit ein vernünftiger spieler drehe
meine runden
sammle die ganze zeit diese punkte ein
werde langsam größer an amano scheiße da
dieser t das ist der grösste [ __ ]
der welt schickt die ganze zeit teile
weg an seine kumpels frist wieder andere
hated dann wieder ist dann aber und de
abonniert main kanal [ __ ] was bei
user aus deutschland
bayern kommt dem geben was ab sagt danke
dir dass du dir die die deutschländer
die der deutschland ag vielleicht euch
einfach schlafen geben dem ganzen mal
einfach noch einen anlauf leute also ich
war ja zu beginn überhaupt hier sind
ticker gleich groß also zu beginn war
ich wirklich relativ gut da hatte ich
diese gute phase wo ich da fast sogar in
den top ten war glaube ich hatte diese
eine riskante aktionen wo ich einfach
die hälfte von mir ausgesandt habe
einfacheres verfahren und tatsächlich
annehmen die zwei drei leute gefressen
habe aber jetzt gerade bin ich quasi
wieder down und ich wurde runtergeholt
auf meinen auf meinen bisherigen
standard da oben ist eine fette fliege
diese runden werden immer besser
ich weiß nicht ob ich in dem spiel
irgendwas falsch mache weil ich ja
vorhin wirklich zu beginn relativ gut
war aber irgendwie machen die anderen
was besser ich glaube es sind einfach
mehr so [ __ ] die dann einfach so
gegenseitig die anderen noch auf presse
und ich konnte ihm jemand auf den
kleinkram hier ich mach das jetzt
einfach mal so dass ich mich direkt zu
zwei teile damit ich hier schneller die
ganze kacke essen kann bleibt vielleicht
weil ich damit der aebi vorteil also ich
kann dann denke ich schneller diese
ganzen kügelchen einsammeln denen davor
ja ok als abgehauen noch mal gerade so
ein bisschen zu lagern hier auch ich
denke dass das video gerade sehr viele
leute sehen die einen kanal sehr häufig
geschaut habe also die ganz finnland
da will ich einmal aber so ein bisschen
überkommenes stimme schon heiser ich
will einmal aber so ein bisschen ihr tut
all time slots goldene alive bekommt
finnland um die ecke und ich bin tot
zu weihnachten bekommen habt das was ihr
vom video meine damen und herren ich
hoffe ich konnte euch ein bisschen
unterhalten sich das konnte dann last
light und wie gesagt bei 400 millionen
1000 likes kommt nächster hat hiervon
hier findet ihr in smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr da draufsteht könnte ihm einen
kanal abonniert dann verpasst ihr keine
videos mehr und das ist kostenlose man
wird auch ein besserer mensch dadurch
hier findet irgendein anderes video
eingeblendet ist locker auch richtig
kacke
gerade auf